[Music]
assistant of the reject Nation before I
go into anything else I wanted to say
that real reix has a new boys inspired
t-shirt just finished it it's coming in
the mail for AMW we wearing it for
episode 7 but I'm going to show you guys
what it looks like right now you should
get it you should get it here it is
ah get it America's ass it's a play on
that is America's ass you get it yeah
you get it
smart cook I love that shirt I love it
can't wait to be wearing for the last
couple episodes J V that shirt is
available at reation shop.com John how
are you I am germinating voraciously in
anticipation oh you're doing it oh Coy
you just got back from nycc hosting
panels how you doing how's your voice
absent and I have no gen V puns because
my brain isn't working and that was
intimidating John all righty well ladies
and gentlemen you know what to do leave
a like on this video subscribe click the
notification Bell cuz we're going to be
covering jmv episode 78 thank you all
have been watching with us and thank you
to all have been joining our patreon
page where over there we offer the full
length Reaction watch along that's where
you sync up with your own copy of gen V
but we also cover several shows over
there exclusively with the highlights
and watch Longs included let's get into
reaction
people remember everything I made you
forget who
whoa oh so this episode's going to start
off with people forgetting and
remembering stuff it's start off with
remembering in the EP and forgetting
there's always a mirror thing that
happen it's a good point go get
Sam now she knows how much she loves him
also you're no can't use that word on
Twitter learn that you were in my head
why the girls get a done
poster okay doing the right thing oh oh
is she going to have the aneurism yeah
she's using too much
power damn look at this she made lank
blue ass set damn went from a super red
set that to a super blue set it's calmer
in here it's homeless you know getting
into God you was the best day of my life
and it's no different than the [__] hole
I grew up in we haven't found out who's
like her benefactor sponsor or what's
the word right you're right we haven't
some someone is vouching she was over
just like the rest of us no she was a
part of it Marie I think we should talk
to her you're just mad because you're
sleeping with
her this some hella manipulation layers
he's going through
help I need some help in here I know
it's true Andre can't touch his trust
his dad
trust pulse is slowing can you spe it up
I don't know I I am what if it kills her
just do something be a hero do some
blood stuff be a hero make the blood go
out of her
eyes that is such a different skill than
explode out blood
yeah oh I like the stranger things like
music she's breathing she's breathing
you do care
who is this that's we haven't met this
person right
was I'm assuming just a guinea pig how
long has she been like this since I
injected the virus two days ago the
control is starting to work the virus
only affects soups this is the payoff
for all the work I've done of Sam a way
to compassionately control s God loves
man kill stuff so dangerous for of V we
will be ready to submit today not until
we're ready we are ready results are
exactly what they'd be looking for it's
the very reason the woods exist that was
two days ago
champ Dr cardos it but we mustn't get
premature what do you mean prematures
when something happens
early she might die in the next like 5
minutes let's see how sick we can make
her o oh my let's develop a biochemical
weapon yeah I an even greater one the on
the at make the hydrogen bomb instead of
the atom bomb it is too round on the top
it needs to be pointy has she ever
pushed this much before who cares is
what she gets from my her
friends she can turn invisible what
Marvel's
crossover what
whoa she has so many Powers is this her
doing or someone taking
her she telekinetic what is happening oh
this
[Music]
guy oh [__]
Happ Me Maybe Kate's more powerful than
we thought maybe she's in your heads
yeah maybe she's like a phoenix
situation going cuz there's like the
house is gone they're not they're not
really there's an impact here maybe
she's got telekinesis and telepathy
Caleb who is that come back please oh
we're in her mind oh this her brother
yeah great call Snap mommy Kate
wait just wait there and she said her
mom hasn't touched touched her ever
since this is a memory like Rogue I
don't feel safe with
her we're in Kate's head it was an
accident why did Caleb listen to me he
never does oh hey do you like dogs you
got a canine unit over here to let your
pet one all right just come with me
great visuals memories R yeah give me a
little distance would you peeling the
bark back to the truth beneath what are
you Soldier Boy
soldja boy what are you doing in here
I'm Gate's imaginary friend when she was
a kid oh no way boyfriend really how
cool how to off diddle that Skittle
flick the bean how to find that man in
the
canoe Soldier Boy pillow she'd raw that
pillow till she saw God oh my God Jen
Ackles having the best time I know you
hey you Kate's new boy boy she really
loves you I know you like hair shorter
boys they come and go but she always
comes back to a little pillow
talk this is as good as the cap Cameo at
the end of homecoming turns out you were
radicalized by the Russians you I'm no
Godless
kamie I'm red
blooded but not Kami red red white and
blue red I fart the star spangle
Banner knock knock who's there go your
face okay
it's like less Grossman Kate want you in
here for some reason you better figure
it out quick though before you get stuck
in here love that you can play it as an
11 because it's literally a figment of
Her Imagination of him
yeah see that that wasn't lightning as a
burst blood vessel Kate's head is
unraveling in real time she becomes a
vegetable so do you oh my god see you
die in here real life deception and the
single most important thing I can tell
you of course no of
oh jeez I love that Cameo so much oh
this could be a really trippy episode
that was such a clever way to have a
came in in this cannon without messing
with the boy's Cannon you came back oh
good Heroes always come back right you
remember they're both so broken in into
each other the best kind of love
Yeah a you to should we yeah you mean
like yeah yes just I've uh he's never
done it right why would he I've never
yeah Theory
confirmed
and and he's
competent
but I want to with you they're so sweet
and weird knowing her luck she's going
to get pregnant right away yeah and
[Music]
die I like how yellow's used positively
in this scene usually yellow is like
unnerving but he's unnerving so it's
like a nice yellow
it's like an 80s love making scene yeah
it's like sweet in a way he's going to
invent the atomic bomb thinking about
this scene for years to come please
don't do something horrible I'm very
worried for the show yeah every thing is
a nightmare I was so worried are you
okay Sam just roll with it man just stay
in stay in the zone this episode brought
you by the letter
f o
damn volume Etc in an
equation
whoa oh Jesus wow keep your distance and
don't let her touch you who is this oh I
see hey recruitment when it All
Began I'm not afraid of you Kate got
soldier boy in the background there
smart with all the Queen B stuff too how
long have they kept you here 9 years I
can't imagine how hard that must be for
you to to Bear you don't have to wear
the gloves if you don't want to I trust
you she so good at manipulating you know
her social skills are actually
surprisingly really good for someone
who's been this caged yeah eye contact
presence your mother is afraid because
you are exceptionally powerful what you
need is help understanding your power so
smart to become the surrogate mom oh
yeah that's a really good point she has
no one yeah so clever sometimes the
thoughts are so loud I feel like I'm
going crazy make the voices stop come to
Professor shet saviors don't take the
blue pill if you take these every day
the voices won't bother you anymore I
would love one of
those historically they work out well do
you like a
hug poor woman oh look at that shot
that's
clever
whoa whoa I haven't been to class in
years
Welcome Back Kid this this a long for
the rer yeah he's just trapped with
them Golden Boy Golden Boy tell hey
sleeping with your
girl you just died but like you know
it's cool
right I'm
Bobby Bobby Drake here's an ice flower
welcome to mut could I cheat off of you
you're going to ride my coattails all
the way to the top they're so at
reincorporating him into the show we we
should we should leave I can't be here
where are you going to go I miss you man
oh oh boy but it's her mind doing this
projection of him that's it's not really
him she thinks I mean she thinks he'd
say do I miss you too man so much but
not so much that I'm you know not
sleeping with your girlfriend you
thought I didn't know no what Andre
what's he talking
about oh damn it was already happening
yeah I was going to say as hasn't going
on that's why it happened so quick and
naturally oh oh they're all going to see
it
great well let us see it yeah come on
it's better than the fragle the other
two they were doing it before that's we
were just
saying happening already oh I totally
didn't capture you guys men yeah it's oh
and he's got the bones on his sweatshirt
too that's a great cuz that boy did
design Choice yeah how many times a week
are you serious no no no Kate she didn't
make you do it did
she you wanted
to I'm sorry I thought you were my best
friend whoa of
my a so long
[Music]
man yeah I don't know they have powers
in her mind go go go go
go damn so she feels guilty I hope so
yeah and he feels guilty it's good they
could reuse all these sets
now getting their money out of all
this
hey oh yeah I was going to say they
separated him do we think he's in there
this isn't Cas mry he fine emerging
worlds yeah you can that's really neat
oh was a mind trip it's all right buddy
it's all right I'll tell you everything
full of [__] breathe deep
breath oh everyone's everyone's got some
dark
secrets oh no she's also been covering
up for everything she's a brilliant
receptionist she does so much love and
Beyond I'd just really and to be the one
that who actually fought him later on
Luke needs cuttingedge treatments that
boy could be homelander strong sometimes
he has a bad reaction if L's getting
Cutting Edge treatments I want him too
always looking up for yourself huh shut
up you were one to talk je we were just
there you weren't looking out for
yourself people just don't understand
the lows it takes to reach Great Heights
so now I want you to promise me as my
new ta that you will always protect me
big job I'm
honored good I guess the lesson is we've
all done terrible things
he said he was juicing Golden Boy what
would any of you done something Jordan
we could have stopped everything right
here cool nice but instead we're a TA
saving our own ass I love drink he was
good or not but he was good to us he was
nice I love how this is also represent
the duality of them
yeah for us to let someone get royally
one's breaking down and crying and one's
angry and standing up oh yeah real
dichotomy on screen yeah oh personified
dichotomy yeah and lots of
duplicitousness oh quite that's also
just a great encapsulation of like so
many conversations that are culturally
happening right now when people get
exposed in like positions of power and
that's a great Point complicity like and
the fact that it was her and him
dialogued out the way it was it's great
that was amazing the time you went
cookie I don't think I can do that 247 I
mean maybe
237 I'm messed up Emma you should be
with someone that isn't well maybe I
want to be with you I mean I'm messed up
too me I have really bad
breath really bad and we both smell like
sweaty popcorn sweaty popcorn what is
sweaty
popcorn hope it's a combination of their
smelling the popcorn in the room not
like popcorn sweaty popcorn is a guy in
this universe he's one of the most
famous Heroes with his butter
Cannon what do you
[Music]
see oh wow he's being Juiced off his
brother oh that's messed up that is wild
oh oh and he's got remember for a moment
oh that's how oh wake up Sam
what this oh
wow how torturous you're going to forget
this is happening oh my God you're going
to forget about the wood that is your
brother is dead oh she has been through
so much you kind of predicted some like
that in the first episode I did I don't
love it I don't love being right but the
delivery is so much harsher this is like
New
Mutants
czy he keeps remembering like like a
damn breaking you're helping him Kate
you're doing a wonderful job oh God they
are so
evil make them
forget no
no
no that she could see you in her own
mind it's a great representation of like
everything falling apart and madness
madness like brainwashing almost oh
no I know that door oh it's time to go
in your mind the bathroom door you got
to get out yeah I think it is is the
thing she's protected herself from so
long thinking about like she has to go
through it which is
acceptance soow we're going to find out
she Dick someone over
yeah you killed them I didn't mean to
you were angry that they barged in and
and everything that happened happened
because you wanted it to what oh is that
she feels no matter how hard you try to
be a hero always be a murderer to me oh
I'll never forgive you and you shouldn't
either
oh you told me it wasn't my
fault who who's the
benefactor minute crying over them what
happened to your brother was an accident
I know that you think it's your fault I
think talking to her yeah for when they
had oh I see you shouldn't be here Kate
oh World turned upside down you can wake
up right now I won't stop you anymore
you're up I'm up you got to forgive
yourself too Kate yeah you're
manipulated me and I know your parents
hurt you that's shett I see it hurt
people hurt people but I wish you would
have chose something different because I
love you and I don't want to love you
because I'll never trust you
again you finally have a choice so wake
the up you don't get to throw this all
away you finally have Choice my the line
that does it so wake up
[Music]
is this real
yes
oh oh thank God you're
here you found
him you have sex
hair
Jordan is
Sam oh boy oh no oh he knows no no no no
he just went through this
oh yeah I was worried about that oh man
did she just come back to get killed oh
no oh no oh no oh no let her go she H
you and she H Luke you don't have to
hurt her
back hey look at me trust me right let
her go indana let it
go
damn what is Shetty doing down there I
don't know they were using Sam to
augment Luke's Powers Shetty was
directing it all so she's the answer we
do this and there's no going back we
going
back I didn't mean to I was just
following your orders yes she
did P She a pancake now what's going on
D oh Jeeps man we killed soup my God
that's great she's so happy they have
the power to do kill soup yeah yeah only
5 mm more that was all now can you make
it
contagious of course of course chus man
Jesus that's going to affect the whole
yeah that's going into season four of
the boys now there's going to be like a
which is a super X-Men thing thing like
having a virus that takes away your
powers or kills you or both uh is very
much I wonder if Garn is doesn't like
this show I know Dereck loves it I've
heard the show is very different Sensi
sensibly from the books I feel like
Garis hates supers and I think here
there a superhero show and like I could
see how I can like the boys but I could
where this would really bother I'm like
the the protagonists are the supers in
this yeah they're getting all the like
positive and they're actually getting
the humans are the bad ones and it's
such a flip the humans are totally bad
where like the boys the humans I mean
there's some terrible humans but but the
humans and
there yeah um but here it's like no all
the humans the parents suck the teachers
suck manipulator yeah who looking out
for themselves but we feel sorry for the
supers and the supers are going to be
one who could help save the day uh that
was brilliant that was my favorite
episode of the season so far absolutely
I think that in episode one are my my
two favorites yeah this the one just
surprised me out of nowhere visually
provocative um mindbending and all
accounts but not just for visual flare
it was doing it to really help serve a
greater narrative overall and a way to
do some just solid visual storytelling
or diving deep
into Kate
Kate's going into Kate's mind and
understanding her backstory more it does
surprise me how good she is that she's
very socially capable that I I would
feel like she'd be a lot shy a lot of
YouTube yeah there's got to be a way
she's like socialized she she has to
like yeah I mean probably just learn via
Media or maybe was trained but it's just
she seems so capable of social it's the
one psychological element of it that
kind of throws me off a tad bit is This
Woman's been so cage and then she goes
to school and she seems like she knows
how to flirt she wants to fix so bad I
think it's just like how do I blend in
how do I fix myself how do I get people
to like me like her whole character is
how do I get people to like me and her
trying to not feel like she's doing the
wrong thing while knowing she is yeah I
think it's I think the answer is there
in the show I don't I don't feel like
it's a flaw or criticism really it was
the one thing that was like huh
interesting well and there's a pretty
solid gap of time between when Shetty
comes and takes her to when we join her
now I mean still like decently young at
that point right I mean nine plus she
looked like n years how long how old do
you think she was when she her brother
did she say was like seven
something 16 and college is like 19 I
think yeah I think you could partly
imagine it as like you're thinking back
on yourself you probably imagine
yourself a little more articulately or
whatever than you were at a younger age
oh that's a good point too like her
memory of herself was probably like you
know social she might be like feral but
yeah maybe through this experience going
away with Shetty that would easily open
her up to you know at least some
sociality with other kids who probably
she's not a fresh Sim experience she's
like a sophomore or Junior so that's why
I was saying I'm like 19 should have
some time because the Monica is the only
freshman right yeah it's a Monica Mar
yeah it's a good thing her Towers went
berserk otherwise it wouldn't have been
able to come to a point of understanding
yeah would never forgive each other
killed would not have suffice have to
Legion wipe everyone and then come
together they had to really go all into
the memory Noggin there and that is the
only way it could really come to a true
sense of understanding is allowing them
to experience it vicariously tell me my
friends forgive each talking about yeah
you just got to go into the minds yeah
those sound bath parties I invite you to
we just get in a room we just five
minut I know everyone's performance here
is so strong though and this is a a
story of like like a lot of superhero
stories a lot of it is about
self-acceptance
and everyone here has a journey of self-
forgiveness self-acceptance and really
zeroing in on everyone's flaws and what
makes them human is is the the Dual
emotions of everyone even right down to
Marie I love I love dealing with that
core memory of hers of seeing how yeah
when she was really young she even there
was a part of her that wanted to use her
power and that part of her lives on
through her sister or like through the
iconography of her sister yeah yeah you
know like I'm not saying she like wanted
to kill or deep down she's an evil per
that's not a baby snake thing like in
that moment you were enraged enough that
you directed this energy you didn't
understand at them rather than it just
happening inexplicably yeah yeah and I
like acknowledging that that that's very
human to me even if that was only 1% of
the moment that character in her little
sister represents the 1% of her that was
just angry even if it was 99% yeah I
love that moment very strong stuff and
uh again great use of Schwarzenegger
coming back I thought that was so clever
they've brought him back like three
different episodes and they have all
felt natural yeah he's like an actual
character Golden Boy
Patrick when did he come back before oh
yeah had another flashback yeah yeah but
all the flashbacks haven't been like
just to have them like they saw
flashbacks yeah they actually we need
them on screen like their narrative like
really functional he served a Creator
ner in the show than I ever would have
expected considering he died in the
pilot yeah no he feels like he's part of
The Ensemble even though he is dead and
his presence looms throughout every
episode great yeah yeah the Jordan stuff
with the the both characters both actors
that play Jordan getting to actually act
opposite each other is so fulfilling
because it fits narratively but it also
shows how well cast it also shows like
how well Logan is is acting as I don't
know the other person's name but how
well London sorry not Logan how well
London is acting like uh their male M
male counterpart but then when you see
them on screen together like how they've
worked on having each other's little
ticks and things but then when they're
facing each other like you were saying
like the guilt and anger versus like in
that moment like The Duality of their
emotion in that section was genius
represented their physicality of when
they switch in and out so it kind of
makes me want to it weirdly makes me
want to go back rewatch The episodes and
see the emotional intentional choices of
when um it's the male counterpart versus
the female counterpart I don't know if
that's the correct terminology I'm
dealing with a a character who could
actually transgender character who could
actually switch in and out yeah all
right the male identifying counter yeah
male presenting male pres I don't know
the the way to not offend I'm sorry um
so yeah but to see the to see that would
be really interesting because they were
two very different emotions in that
moment right right right I thought that
was fascinating cuz like you said
everyone got their character Arc but
theirs was the visual representation of
what everyone was actually feeling which
is the dichotomy of the emotion they
were going through I'm surprised it
wasn't rushed this epod like this
normally it's a short episode yeah this
is the shortest I think run time but the
most stuff and it was really thick and I
think it's because you're just diving
straight on into something where you're
not relying you're you're dealing with a
lot of things that are going really in
your face about it yeah while
simultaneously having just enough
exposition to deal with it that you're
you have to face it so head on as an
audience member with the characters that
you surprised they don't feel like
they're rushing through
arcs it manages to be thoughtful without
losing momentum and without losing
tension cuz like at one point I was
afraid actually that we weren't I think
it was with Jordan they have this start
the conversation in the office about
like you know the whole complicity of of
them you know backing up Brink and why
and then you know that conversation
continues sort of into the next scene
and then transitions into the next
character and uh and I don't know I just
I thought that was like kind of graceful
Within this and it's an episode where I
didn't really notice the time and then
you can like I thought just to add to
that like the the Jordan's talk is also
great because so much of what this show
deals with is cycles of pain and and
cycles of I don't know power dynamics
and oppression and stuff like that but
also how people can be complicit and lie
to themselves about why they do that
stuff and also you know the idea that
you might know somebody who is you know
not who they seem to be and they're good
to you and they're you know a positive
presence in your life but meanwhile
they're hurting other people that's like
such a close toome discussion that so
many things have bungled that I thought
this handled really nicely within that
one character of like look at where we
are we're a TA we could have actually
like helped some people not be I mean
you know there's a greater system at
play we probably would have gotten taken
down in the process but we could have
done the right thing in the face of this
instead of accepting all those lies of
oh he's like a father to me oh he's this
he's that and uh and yeah it's like in
an episode like this I'm surprised that
they it's to the writing and the
directing and everyone's credit that it
feels as graceful as it does cuz that
felt like a really thoughtful and a
great example of one of these things
that's in the style of such popular
media that's often trying to like throw
you out a woke idea or something like
that but that's like a super thoughtful
moment within something that's still
moving and still sci-fi and it's still
all the other things that you want I
agree and and and to add to that I I
think not only does it do all of those
things but the speed is able to
accomplish so much because each of their
sections not only Builds on the last one
but they share so much trauma that like
say Jordan's like guilt about the TA
thing mirrors the guilt that Marie feels
mirrors the guilt so they can jump into
the next scene and ride the emotional
wave of whatever that emotion is like
you're falling out of one person
suddenly spiking and guilt going to the
other person's guilt so it doesn't need
two scenes it needs one and a half into
the next person's half and the next
person's half so the pacing gets to be
genius because we've all lived for five
episodes going to this sixth building to
this climax of you have to actually
address this thing that happened to you
and then we know the 78s of the setup
then this one we got like all of that in
Rapid Fire through the emotional
connection which is genius what is the
okay what's the dean's name and what's
Clancy Brown's name Shetty and Brink
shett is the dean Brink is the what I
think what I think the show has really
laced throughout this whole season in
particular so well is is the focus on
the parents and how the parents have
been pretty abusive and they accepted a
deal that would monetize and take
advantage of their kids and yet they
would also judge and condemn them uh for
not going down certain paths they want
like the parents are Terri like are
awful sure I mean I feel like I'm
blanking on maybe a good one good parent
foot I kind but for the most part
they're they're all awful or dead and
then what they've done with Shetty and
Brink is they have made them both the
surrogate father and mother I totally
agree when you mentioned br's like
paternal presence I think said it to one
point I'm like oh wow that's a really
good way to make it like hey you need me
you haven't had me exactly they they
totally they like prey on children who
it's it's like it's such a weird cycle
of what VA does yeah of they uh persuade
these parents take advantage of the
parents and then they like they make
sure the parents are like terrible
[__] people yeah and then they step
in and become the parents to the kids
you this episode was we haven't
mentioned the best Cameo I've seen a
long time yeah it's about my mind I was
just about to think cuz all the stuff
you're saying I'm like all right and
then the first typ of the episode does
all the stuff with VA but personifies it
in the most ridiculous like H Rock
Character and allows him to be an 11
allows him to say all the stuff that
clearly Jin nles has been dying to say
for years like the joy in that
performance but it personifies what VA
has been doing not only as the the you
know boyfriend the guy the the guy I'm
dating in Canada element but also what
that represents in this show and what
super represent in this world it was
cool that he got to play the the image
of soldier boy yeah and not cuz we we we
know what Soldier Boys really like right
he got to play like the caricature of
yeah but he still have the beard and
everything oh so good but like
reded yeah yeah that was really fun I
fart Spangles like it was just so many
great I want to rewatch just that scene
to experience the dialogue again in real
time because it was masterfully
delivered and ridiculous that was so fun
seemed like they let him riff oh that
definitely was like
the kind of cutting that was happening
there it it works great cuz it's like it
could be an improv bit but because of
the kind of jarring cutting it works
with the weird types of way your mind
moves at a rapid Pace I want the seven
minute cut of just Jens snackles going
to town cuz I guarantee it's out there's
got to be like I hope you know they
always do the on a day and then four
days later Amazon's like okay let's get
the other half the people that didn't
watch and then they just release that
please Amazon release the Jens knackles
cut yeah yeah um man there's a lot of
happen here because that oh no I was
going to say that was terrific but also
uh uh Emma and Sam like that whole
subplot up together was like the
sweetest counter I thought that was a
really nicely placed Counterpoint cuz
that could have happened a lot of places
the was great but yeah it's like it's
you have a me a crazy mental intimacy
happening on the one hand as we get to
our Chara it's like this is the
character climaxes episode before we
take it to the streets so like which is
weird usually the penultimate yeah it's
usually episode seven this was six but
the climax had to come early cuz it's
its first time sure sure and I thought
they made that really sweet whilst also
incorporating still you know the the
like you have that dread of like is this
going to become like a a bad trip and it
does become a sort of hallucination but
it doesn't become a bad trip and it does
kind of read yeah like this 80s kind of
awkward but super sweet and endearing
kind of moment yeah I like that it
didn't ruin the moment but it definitely
made you like worried for her it built
it built tension and and it gave it
Stakes but like the sky sex didn't
become like a negative thing for him too
long yeah and it's the kind of thing
that in this universe is usually so
lurid and so kind of used for shock and
humor that it was nice to see A Moment
Like That treated with tenderness and
actual yeah just kind of like character
intimacy felt real did very very much so
yeah that was great that was beautiful
and I think this might be my favorite
episode this is a th% my favorite
episode by by like there's not even a
competition honestly episode one was
just so unique in that it it balanced so
many tone but I think this one wins
though cuz you're right this is just it
it accomplished so much in like 30
something minutes um but I gotta say
man Andre seems like an awful person
yeah he's the only one I'm like he's
actually the only his Arc exactly he
does not seem humbled by this situation
the second
after the second after he gets caught
he's like way to not be accountable and
I was like you're boning dudes girl the
second scene and I liked his plea to her
to wake up and I I liked his admission
of love but yeah of all the character
that had such kind of touching Journeys
and and very clearline Journeys well
what I like about him is he he seems
like he he's the one who propels them to
want to do heroic acts like what I still
believed even though he was criticizing
uh Jordan in that moment I did believe
him when he said I would have done
something and I know and I feel like he
would have done something and it's a
different kind of thing it's a different
kind of thing it's a completely
different thing and I still think that
even though I still feel like he would
have tried to like do the right thing in
terms of oh this really cruel things
happening to Luke right yeah yeah yeah
to Luke um real real cruel things
happening to Luke he would have tried to
do something as we've seen in Prior
episodes he will still try to do the
heroic path and uh yeah I think I'm
playing it the consequences of other
actions later but there still seems to
be like there's yeah there still seems
to be this lack something that I've been
we've been talking about is like it
seems like there's this lack of guilt
well there's a lack of accountability
everyone else has some accountability
for their actions every single other
character like good bad everything in
the middle human has an accountability
and he's just like you're all [__] up
why I'm like dude you're you're you're
sleeping with her but when you he was
alive you contined to sleep with her
it's just Justified because you love her
well and and it's also I think very
College I think it's maybe it makes
sense as to why it happens this way but
I think it is maybe the one episode
aspect of the episode that gets garbled
by the fact that that becomes a sort of
action moment because he Flames out and
you know it becomes about you know not
being obliterated in fact does that one
guy die for real yeah so yeah like that
guy got got smoked got splattered so
yeah it's like instead of having him and
Luke have like a scene type resolution
you know that was a representation of it
we kind of stone skip away from that I
feel like yeah I think we need I still
feel like there needs to be something
more uh developed in that Arena and then
now they're controlling they have a way
to control the soups yeah they've got a
weapon yeah woof hell yeah imp it's
coming it's got to affect boy season 4
unless unless they just burn this all
down likee eight or something yeah no I
feel like I feel like didn't get out
it's a new Stakes element especially
with homelander being as powerful he is
and the Way episode uh season 3 ended I
mean because if from the trajectory of
homelander who has been playing so much
by his own
rules uh it's like a big part of how vot
has been able to control soups has been
them wanting to be liked to put it in
the most simplistic terms you know
especially homelander on the most like
Amplified level of of really caring what
people think about him and he just wants
to be loved and now he's been doing that
by just doing his own thing he even
kills he even kills someone in the
middle broad daylight on everyone's like
W homelander uh just some random guy in
a crowd but he wants to be admired and
like once he realizes that's admiration
it's like well that's what I've been
wanting to do and then you got these
Millennials yeah all these genz kids get
yeah genz who wants to do their own
thing you want to come up and be a real
hero not a selfish one and now they need
to they need to find a way to control
the thing they created right and this
would be it and if they have a weapon
that could literally murder them yeah
that changes the stakes for the rest of
the univers crazy I wonder if our boys
like get involved buter would want to
something like this oh he definitely
would yeah but he's also got compound V
in his veins now so does Jack or so does
huie so we don't know who's representing
Marie though
still yeah and I can't put a theory on
it it's her
sister yeah there's no I imagine it's a
boy's Cameo but I can't think of any boy
that would be like a benefactor for
anyone everyone's too selfish in the
boys like the seven are all like who I
feel like there's got Starlight cuz she
thinks that she can like help from
inside I don't know like it's such a
stretch yeah it's Starlight May how
crazy it would be for ma oh isn't she
isn't she dead Ma's not dead wait M's
dead is ma dead did they fake her death
or is she actually dead oh I got to
rewatch
it cuz I was I was going to say that
then I had the thought of like wait a
minute though didn't did she die or did
she or or was it a kind of thing
where also I've got a medium issue where
I'm like am I remembering reading or
watching yeah yeah yeah I feel like it'd
be laced throughout the season season if
she was dead maybe I'm thinking of print
print media Crimson count has definitely
died she did but uh she handed her last
hand homelander wouldn't do it uh no no
no I mean Adrian wouldn't really have a
good reason to do it who who plays Jim
Jim Beaver what was his character he's
like a he's like a politician I don't
know why he would do it yeah would uh
it'll be Jared
pad oh buter would he like want a soup
in the inside mother's milk is her
uncle
what uh what happened with John car her
name is m too she's an mm holy [__]
though she is an mm she's Marie Maro
they could be like distantly related
what's his real name I don't remember if
that's really funny name like Calvin or
something but but if she wears any sort
of hip-hop t-shirt at one point we'll
know they're because of all of his great
what happened with John Carlo again he
he he had the he was in power and then
homelander took
over we should rewatch season 3
something to do with head exploding girl
didn't he like Mentor her or
something yeah trained her and then she
betrayed him she and she and homelander
were like both yeah and he like was
using
her you know the chat right now Message
Board is like it's obviously this like
what was it but if he's out of
vot maybe he's a been he got money would
would he yeah he would I mean would he
be trying to like
Mentor I mean like I'm not sure I think
it's like an inside job situation I
don't think it's mentoring I think it's
like someone wants someone in the seven
that's under their thumb I think someone
that's why I feel like wouldn't wouldn't
what was John Carlos character's name
again uh uh edar Stan Edgar yeah what
would would he maybe he would try to use
her to go back in maybe but that's why I
was thinking like cuz I'm trying to
think not just character but also
motivation sure well and what would it
be about her in particular what what is
it about her power that moment she could
take out homelander probably yeah I mean
she's got power well especially if she
can like percolate his blood and stuff
like that yeah that's fair that is like
a it is a
uniquely we see it used to make like
blades and things a lot but I feel like
they've made a really cool point over
the season continuing that she can do
yeah these other things internally also
they should animate Carnage like that
it's so cool and gross yeah but you know
yeah she can heal but she can also like
Rend you from the inside out so I mean
yeah she would be a pretty powerful
seven number yeah I think butcher is a
possibility just because the leverage
within the seven I think that uh Stanley
Edgar is a great idea I want it feels
like a big but is Butcher literally
going to show up in episode 8 like hey I
need more people on my team like you
know
I you had potential she's on the seven
and then he's like how do you think you
got here like CU I think she fully
becomes a member of the seven and then
your boy Jack qu seems to hang out with
these guys it's true uh oh is he coming
and is he gonna be Nick Fury got no
suddenly got like I'm help you to God
you H's out there selling compound V on
the streets every time they say God you
too it just makes so good it's such a
great douchy name for people that are
trying to be God douche name all righty
guys well it's a good one it was a good
one that was a great episode that's my
favorite one so far easily so good ex
thank God for that Soldier Boy Cameo one
might get views that's what I'm talking
about we appreciate you internet for
only caring my not for the great episode
not for great writing or any boy we got
halfway through our commentary and I was
like we hav mentioned so boy the
internet we'll want that yeah that's for
guys uh leave your thoughts down below
leave a like on this video that'd be
very much appreciated what's your
favorite MCU C leave it below get
yourself in America's ass tape and hey
let's send this with a patron of the day
shout out all right guys we got to do
some Patron catch UPS here and going
within the theme we're going to use our
friends over at chat gbt to help us get
to know what people might be like when
our patrons interact with each other now
we're down to our last few we are and
here's the problem with the last few yes
we don't know them personally that well
no normally we have some facts about
them and then we throw it in there but
now we're just going to have to take a
guess on what they're like to judge
people based on their name have to
assume some of their personality traits
just off of the little bits of
interactions that we've had with them
definitely all right so let's get this
show on the road so I have a YouTube
channel I'm prompting chat to you to I'm
going to shout out our patrons are super
sexy rejects uh which pair should we go
with John oh let's do Brian Perry and
pandemic Jones oh my God what's pandemic
Jones's real name Paul Brian Perry and P
and Paul Jones yes all right all right I
want you to write a scene only do the
dialogue of
them of them um escaping from
Leatherface in oh yeah oh no it's we'll
put this in the saw video escap jigsaw
escaping from
jigsaw create a they are trapped
together create a trap that they have to
survive together to get out of yeah and
what must they learn throw jigsaw in
there at the beginning yeah jigsaw tape
the beginning a jigsaw a jigsaw saw tape
some facts about Brian Perry and Paul
Jones all right Paul likes to be called
pandemic Jones likes to be called
pandemic Jones that's true it's awarded
nickname uh he's a very upbeat and uh
good-spirited person upbeat and
good-spirited person okay but but why
would he need to be taught a lesson from
jigsaw cuz he wants to cause a pandemic
cuz he's too online he's always online
he wants to cause a pandemic he wants to
cause a pandemic that's even better um
we yeah always online never living too
much in his in the real world in the
real world yeah in the moment um he he
has has has stolen fruit from the
grocery store oh no and uh let's see how
old do you think he is uh he's like 23
23 years old yeah
male um very buff very buff but with
glute impacts uh glute uh implants and
lies to people that he did it all
natural oh no oh my God okay now Brian
Perry I really don't know much about
this guy we shout him out all the time
so we's going to take I guess um okay
he's a cop I think in real life he's a
cop it's a s I believe Brian is probably
our oldest Patron he is 98 years old
he is he's old on 90 years old and he's
been scamming his Medicare been scamming
his Medicare has had has had three to
four wives yes um who have all
mysteriously disappeared disappeared um
oh he's uh obsessed with Mel Gibson
yeah yeah he's a he loves qanon loves Q
how do you spell q and on that's how
woke I am space a n o n loves q and on
just the letter Q uh uh ooh he's uh he
he he makes inappropriate comments to
people online inappropriate comments to
people
online uh and but overall a nice
guy all right make sure to create the
Trap let's do this let's see how
creative you can be let's see if they
can write the next saw installment let's
do this saw
XI saw levam all right take it away John
interior dimly lit room night Paul
pandemic Jones and uh Brian Perry find
themselves in a dimly lit grim room
their eyes adjust to the darkness as
they both realize they are chained to
opposite walls a large electrical panel
with tangled wires between them above
the panel a monitor flickers on
revealing the Eerie puppet face of jig
saw hello Paul and Brian let's play a
game Paul your online Persona has
consumed you making you miss out on the
genuine experiences of life and Brian
despite your service you've made choices
that conflict with your role as a
protector of
society uh to escape this room you must
literally reconnect with each other no
the screen shows a demonstration there
are 10 wires five from Paul's side and
five from Brian's they must match the
right wire to each side to form five
correct pairs a wrong match sends an
electrical shock it's like this video
game this is so light uh Paul your
thefts from The Real World represented
by the fruits of your labor will guide
Brian and Brian your knowledge of True
Crime will help Paul but hurry you have
five minutes before the room becomes
your final resting place the screen goes
dark all right I'll be Brian all right
trying to maintain some composure all
right pandemic let's put aside our
differences and we're together I faced
tougher situations in many years all
right Oldtimer I must be all oh let's do
it again all right then I don't
know all right pic let's our differences
we M together I face tougher situations
in my years all right Old Timer I might
be all about the Dig digal world but
right now we're very much in the real
one let's do this I us to see symbols in
my end a melon an apple a banana reminds
me of Mel Gibson movie when you was a
thief I can't recall the name of that
movie but I think it happened
once this is a real trap is to figure
out what that movie is uh those are the
fruits I stole match the melon with the
green wire on your side what symbols Do
you have a bloody C badge a wedding ring
a Medicare card a q symbol and an online
comment section okay connect the badge
with the blue wire we've got this
minutes feel like hours as they continue
connecting wires getting uh minor shocks
along the way but ultimately finding the
right connections you know for someone
assists with online stuff you're not
half bad in person and for a cop with
such a twisted past you're not the worst
partner in a tight spot with the final
wire connected the chains release
freeing them we did it kid we sure did
old man that's it they that's all you
could created escaped the deadly tra
Nails learn they learned the value of
genuine connection what a great setup
you totally canned everything about I
know you didn't include Jolan I'm going
to I'm going to criticize
GB notes rewrites yeah oh my God you
didn't include Jack about Paul's back
background that we gave you it was so
light it was so
light apologies over sight all right
we're going to redo this all right we
got the
Trap pass Secrets oh no there's a whole
different track oh my God it's totally
redoing the scene oh it's redo doing
everything Paul pandemic Jones and Brian
Perry trapped in a room Bound by chains
between them are a series weights and
pulley attached to Paul's side as a
heavy weight marked virtual world on
Bryant's side there's an even heavier
weight labeled past Secrets above them a
tape recorder dangles Paul manages to
nudge it and it begins to
play I yeah
sure
sayic jigaw here s
you've been lost in the virtual world so
consumed by your digital life that
reality eludes you Brian your past is
heavy with Secrets weighing you down and
preventing you from moving forward today
you must face those burdens together to
escape ball you must physically lift
your weight symbolizing your online
obsessions Brian to help him reveal the
secret of every Milestone Paul achieves
making your weight lighter and easier to
lift if neither of you is honest or
committed neither of you gets out
remember sometimes the heaviest burdens
we carry are the ones we hide the tape
clicks off that's good all right there's
like two lines of dialogue let's see
what the hell they do okay struggling to
lift okay I'll admit it these glutes not
all natural I got implants but I tell
everyone I got them from squats
confession time okay wife number two it
wasn't a mysterious disappearance she
left me for a Mel Gibson
impersonator they continue in this vein
each Revelation lightening the weights
bit by bit I I might want to cause a
pandemic online but I'm terrified of
real life confrontations and I've never
actually confronted my feelings for well
real people I've scanned Medicare oh
true not because I needed the money but
because I felt invisible in my old age I
just wanted to feel
seen F finally finally after much effort
and the Revelation the chains release
you know for an old cop you've got quite
the story and you kid might want to
spend a bit more time in the real world
it's not all that
bad this was a better version Chad GPT I
like that Chad GPT came up with traps at
least these are jigsaw esque traps all
right in like 10 seconds it's not too
bad that's your shout out guys we tried
it we we did
[Music]
it